uh today hatred mail does make a
triumphant return to the show
if you don't remember what hatred mail
is here's a reminder
we're getting to the oranges of this
investigation
so god bless united states america
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate
david pakman because america
and because freedom
yeah so hatred mail is when a
professional
uh voice-over artist does interpretive
readings of the hate mail that i get
here is one from someone who
simultaneously seems just obsessed with
me
but also seems to very much dislike me
who is
david pakman is he married
and fatard below me is correct
women pick their man i mean she should
have married you
a loser youtube commentator she seems
like she has an okay
life first world problems huh pacman
you are a loser sign up to become
unhinged loon with pacman
report the news of trump's victories i'm
not a fan of david cuckhold pakman
surprisingly or maybe not i mean maybe
this is actually a common psychological
phenomena
it's really common that some of the
people who seem to
despise me the most because of my
political views and and the program i
host
also seem obsessed with the minutia of
everything i'm doing everything i'm
saying my life and whatever else
it's actually not altogether uncommon
among hatreds and
maybe that's surprising maybe it's not i
don't know uh but remember that
you can fight patriotism in your
communities
by using the coupon code hatred 40 any
membership at joinpakman.com
can be instantly discounted by 40
with the coupon code hatred 40. the
hatreds hate it when that coupon code is
used and it's spelled
h-a-t-r-i-o-t-4
0.